brotes verdes al fin en shanghai cuando
se cumple un mes y medio del inicio de
la peor crisis desde los días dejan dos
de los 16 distritos de shanghai no ha
registrado ningún contagio fuera de las
zonas de cuarentena y en otros 7 los
contagios no han superado la decena de
casos los contagios totales por su parte
han bajado por primera vez en mucho
tiempo del umbral psicológico de los
20.000 y las autoridades aseguran que
han frenado la expansión del virus por
la comunidad más de 16 millones de los
25 millones de sanhan s siguen
encerrados en casa por un brote que ha
causado según las cifras oficiales 17
muertos todos ellos son ancianos que
estaban sin vacunar porque tenían
enfermedades previas que se lo habían
impedido el freno de la pandemia
coincide con el reinicio
paulatino de la actividad industrial más
de 600 compañías de sectores clave como
el médico el tecnológico o el
automovilístico han abierto ya sus
puertas o lo harán en breve a cambio las
autoridades exigen que los trabajadores
vivan en las fábricas no hay
instrucciones concretas sobre tienen que
adecuarlas para que puedan pernoctar
pero algunas compañías ya han empezado a
repartir sacos de dormir y esterillas